it's no secret that clash Royale died so
why'd it happen here's the top by reason
that clash Royale failed and we're
starting right after this welcome to
Haris Abhi's so starting off with a
smaller issue there was an endless
stream of cards and you can never really
have all of them there was originally
only 42 cards 14 of each type epic rare
and commons eventually to Legendary's
would be added which were the ice wizard
and the princess and this was a great
balance these were extremely hard to get
and were quite unique and special but
after this they continuously added more
legend areas like the log in the lava
hound and Sparkie soon enough it became
nearly impossible to collect all of them
if you were a free-to-play player the
chance of getting off the legendaries
for free was slim to none before when
there were only two lenders it was
actually possible but now what's a slew
of legendaries it was very hard and this
cost supercell to make getting legendary
is much easier and this made legendary
way to a common they were just like any
other card today there are 93 cards
which is over double the original amount
of cards and there are 16 legendaries
which is more than any type had
originally and you really can't go to
battle without seeing a legendary card
being played before it used to be
something unique but now it's just a
normal card well at least the problem
collecting all of them is eliminated
right well that may be true but it's
really no use if you can't level them up
the legendary cards that you get is
fully up to chance and if you only get a
legendary card every couple of weeks
it's pretty much impossible to level em
up to a decent level and this problem
doesn't just apply to legendary cards
all new cards take a while to upgrade
and get to a useable level and with the
endless stream of cards coming out by
the time that you upgrade a card to a
usable level a new card is already and
this has led to players stagnating and
using the same decks over and over again
that they have highly leveled up there
really was not that much diversity and
this has led to another problem which is
repetition new cards really had no value
as players used the cards that they had
leveled up this was one of the main
superself continued to endlessly launch
cards they wanted to keep the game
diverse and interesting but this really
didn't help as people continue to use
what they were used to even if you
leveled up new cars or open to new decks
you probably wouldn't change because
cards were overpowered unfortunately the
game was pretty much always unbalanced
and favored certain cards there was
really no reason to use new cards when
you were not only more used to the old
cards but they were also more effective
this led to decks that you would see
very frequently in cars that were used
heavily these included cards like the
hog rider logs app and skeletons and if
you didn't run into a person who was
using one of these cards you probably
ran to someone who was using an
overpowered deck with a certain card for
example you saw everyone used a bomb
tower Wang lasted one minute
you saw everyone use hog freeze when the
freeze had a radius of 4 tiles you saw
everyone used elite barbarians when it
dealt too much damage you saw everyone
used a royal giant went had too large of
a range despite the huge number of cards
that are being released only a few of
them would actually catch on every
battle you face the same thing over and
over again either you face time this
decks that never got outdated or
overpowered decks and this is very
boring for both players you keep doing
the same thing if you're pushing you may
drop a hog Raider followed up by Galvez
and get ready to zap if you're defending
your profit dropped back in or some sort
of building and then troops to support
it and if you're facing overpowered deck
there's really not much you could do
because it's not an even playing field
in the end the unbalance cards really
caused repetition which led to either
frustration or boredom which both led to
people quitting the game now as we just
discussed the newer cards were really
not very effective at keeping people
playing but the new remotes were
actually very effective at keeping
people interested in the game but
unfortunately a new good mode hasn't
been released in two years the first new
mode they added was tournaments and that
was pretty useless as it was not
beneficial to the average player
tournaments costed hundreds of gems to
hosts and it simply wasn't worthwhile
for the average player it was
very tough to get a sizable return as a
cost to benefit ratio was very bad and
then they added challenges classic and
grand challenges and this was actually a
really good idea as it was pretty cheap
at ten and hundred jeomsun respectively
this was actually within the range after
Irish player and it was actually pretty
worthwhile and then they came out with
the new booth for challenges like
instant death double Lix for triple
elixir and then they came out with team
challenges are based on new cards
holidays or events like the Super Bowl
these were all really great ideas and
offered great incentives for people to
continue to play and then a little more
than a year after launch they released 2
v2 mode and this was also very effective
at keeping people playing this led to
completely different strategies and new
decks and this was the first time that
you got to work with their friends and
buddies you were always just going
against them and I'm not sure who
thought of this but only offering it for
a limited time at the beginning was a
genius idea
this left people yearning for the next
time that 2v2 would be available and
really got people to play the game once
again eventually 2v2 would become
permanent but this was a perfect way to
launch the new mode but unfortunately
this is really the last major good thing
to come out and that was in May of 2017
the only significant release has come
since is clan wars which is honestly
pretty terrible collection days
basically want to be one in two be two
battles in different modes there's
really no incentive and then on bad day
you're not even directly battling
another clan now I think that we all
understand that it's hard to match up
two people from two different clans at
the same time and doing that for every
single member while keeping the playing
field even this was technically the only
feasible way of actually establishing
clan wars but this way took out the
spirit of winning and clan wars winning
or getting first place in a clan war
really wasn't very fun or intriguing and
without a new intriguing mode being
released over the last two years
millions of players have left and that
thing is when there's nothing new people
start to feel satisfied with their
progress as you guys probably already
know in class Rio there are a bunch of
different leagues and 4000 is pretty
much to max
League of course there are still leagues
over 4,000 but once you pass 4,000
Profis you lose half the trophies over
4,000 every single season and you get to
a point where you have to pay to move
along in the game or be very serious
about the game and there's really
nothing left to do for the average
player for thousands pretty much the
goal and once you get there you were
done with the game there's no reason to
continue to battle and risk dropping
under 4,000 trophies even if you keep
winning matches you're eventually going
to be reset down anyways so a lot of
people just don't see a incentive there
and plus it's not like you miss out on
anything either because you can always
do 2v2 and still get chests and rewards
and there's no repercussions in losing
to be two battles eventually after
quitting 1v1 battles people quit the
game as a relay no incentive to continue
now let me be clear it's not a sudden
change you get to 4,000 you quit it's
much more of a slow transition once it
passed 4,000 trophies a lot of people
aren't motivated to do 1v1 battles and
as a result it turned to 2v2 bowels
initially and eventually you quit the
game without even realizing it now
what's a clash royale and pretty much
all of supercells game apart was that
they were free to play and this
attracted a completely new demographic
but other companies were witnessed how
much success supercell was getting and
they would released their own
free-to-play games and these are not
small companies are making their first
game and finally entering the gaming
industry
these are established game publishers
who know exactly how to make a really
good game and when they're offering it
for free people are obviously going to
flock towards them and disliked intense
competition for clash Royale the first
of which being pokemons go if you take a
look at Google Trends you can see a
clear negative spike on the week that
pokemons go was released
luckily for supercell Pokemon go really
didn't catch on and it was more of a
fade and players returned to class right
out but new competition continued to
appear and obviously the biggest
competition at clash Royale faced was
fortnight Mobile Epic Games launched a
serious first-person shooter for free
this was never before seen and led to
previously unimaginable Heights
fortnight traffic
ky rocketed especially as they were
available on every single platform
everyone had at least one of these
devices and this really took a lot of
interest away from clash Royale and more
recently just last year was the release
of pubsey Mobile clearly competition the
free-to-play mobile space has really
risen since clasher always released and
this has really hindered its
sustainability so how is a clash rail
doing today well recently supercell
actually launched a pretty significant
update they launched something called
the pass trial which as it sounds very
similar to the battle pass from
fortnight it allows you to earn a unique
Awards of perks by earning crowns
clearly they're really trying to add new
features and incentives and get people
interested once again but as of now
nothing has really caught on and as of
March 2019 there was 317 million clash
for accounts but only 14 million of them
were actually active accounts this means
that only point four four percent of all
clash real accounts are actually active
and these active accounts are
concentrated in the king glove was ten
eleven and twelve evidently supercells
main demographic the casual gamer has
left a long time ago and that is
unfortunately where clash Royale stands
today clash Royale was not only one of
the most popular mobile games but one of
the most popular games in the world in
general they dominated right off the bat
and really kept players interested for
quite a while with all the new modes and
challenges that kept the game refreshing
but eventually players either began to
feel bored of the game or satisfied with
their progress and this combined with
rising competition it really was just a
matter of time before the game
completely died out and that's really
what's happening right now
however Flash morale was a very fun game
while lasted and it will always have a
special place in many for hearts but
that's not half are you guys on clash
Royale make sure comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you guys liked this video they
mixed up a like and consider subscribing
you cuz I'd see more videos just like
this one run till then I'm Ari I'll see
you guys on that
[Music]